well you can get and they all live in LA
that'll be good guys yeah yeah that
you'd like
you should get uh you should get Eminem
thanks Chris about to see a bad joke I
am launching all right let's just go
yeah no more let's just get this is
serious now this is trials trial I said
that 100 delicious
is that that Dave Chang thing yep
i watch some of it it's good legit talk
about my chicken basically it's
basically each episode is about a
designated like food and like you know
gun
yeah they got and Z and and sorry
whatever sorry they got the actions
correctly no I'm not in it David chosen
it his mom's in it that's right yeah for
the cream we can do a dude you get a
team you can do it you're my god sorry
Craig this is your idea Craig what's
wrong [ __ ] ball you gonna do this
dude we don't need Co no dude
what happened already
yeah Griffin wants to go play
battlefront with Bobby Lee oh don't say
that everybody'll be upset I wanted to
play with Barbie I like I think he is
I'm pretty sure sissies I'm like yeah
dude
Griffin likes to play that regardless he
like he loves again no he's watching TV
he was playing bound on earlier though
trout all night we're here oh no I don't
like this man says we can do it thanks
buddy yeah well just do it like maybe
two or three goes and then that's it I
mean yeah started getting spanked here
yeah let's do two and then we can watch
it yeah all right yeah and then we'll
just call it
[Music]
where'd you get that armor over for
eight months and oh oh it's from this
guy's 133 games
68 okay [ __ ] cray and look at them
they all have like the same outfits and
[ __ ] yeah they all have the ornaments
for the practice anyway alright it's
practice anyway what's that a kale unit
let's set a cave they're coming dead I
need help
well I got one I got one like an inch
this is so yeah we're not gonna well
these guys are like pros let's just
practice so we go three like you're
gonna go Dan they're gonna go camp but
I'm gonna check with tree first yeah
they're going cave trees empty cave keV
keV keV get mining already yeah of
course error I say we go tree next time
I you know I don't know this level that
welcome yeah
Pikachu he's right and thank you
he's behind you well you got that guy
[Laughter]
well I'm doing good go tree go tree go
tree I'm going with Craig up there I'm
gonna shield up in front of it all right
now just keep him off keep back keep
back let's go back and keep off I'm dead
before I could do anything
stroker nades Adam throw grenades you
got this who's alive he could try a
grenade of them Craig just gotta give us
your idea okay it's also this
invisibility they're gonna fix it jesus
[ __ ] all
yeah it's just all in Virginia horseshit
I know but it's also they're all in
Jersey no hey don't worry Steve because
the updates coming soon and the shit's
all going oh yeah they're gonna fix make
the dump and then biz and it's gonna be
more yeah we all got kills family all
right it's bum rush to cave [ __ ] it
let's let's take em a cave we'll end it
quick or no hey see if you know mind me
asking yes here we go asking what are
you [ __ ] the audience come on man
game I couldn't even move I could not it
was a good try dude we have two more
rounds they're all gonna have their
supers so it's just gonna be one and
done well that's not the game this is it
no all right they're going cave let's go
to the tree and get the heavy and then
go where is the heavy I don't let it or
it is over he's right here right here
Greg come here all right all right I'm
not by Steve you're gonna kill us anyway
they're not even to give me time to get
it dude guaranteed
I'm [ __ ] go Steve got one off good job
Steve you guys got this just disarmed
disarmed folders I told you this was
gonna be bad all right let's go to Iron
Man Oh see that was worth the pikachu's
all right take us to the tickets that's
six coming or March 27 I'll be good what
they're they're using their invisibility
yeah yeah they're finding no more the
cysts they're bluffing pulse rifles are
booking everything else
what's really what's been watching
lately Steve what you've been doing no
I'm just [ __ ] trying to keep the show
going deny elation oh how was it
Danna wanted to go with old man yeah I
got it was good or it was just okay I
liked it I liked it all right not to
check it out I like that director
are you guys gonna check out ready
player one when it comes up yeah even
though I'm not a fan of one of the
persons that works on it but yeah I'll
check it out I love the book dude okay
why don't you just watch it
there's a lot of stories behind it man
talk about a Weinstein
it's the Weinstein dude he touched me
you touched me in my regions look who's
talking
you're always talking about people
touching your regions yeah you have all
the time
you said that one time you're drunk
banana touched your region see there was
no denial see yeah you guys all went for
it he said he also heard good dilation
I'll check it out sounds good three went
black yeah error oh wait no dude just
started up to you we're here bro yeah
we're here iron banner
yeah we'll kill it an iron banana what
are you looking forward to what else you
guys looking forward to is there
anything good coming out I'm just I
think that anymore yeah that new I like
I want to see that new lost in space
what's that all about
the New Avengers Finney do you work
there measures I'll do things so sick so
you know I lost in space that's good
dude mark my words I think lost in space
is gonna be good enough
Stevie it's literally what the MCU has
been working on for all these years
in like two weeks
okay when they did the like that's what
this is like superheroes CGI Superman
movie for 10 years yeah he's nice you
know I did my thing and what's worked on
my thing too bro that's what I'm talking
about
Tom I'm definitely down for some Red
Dead - I'm waiting for God awarded I'm
looking forward to God over ya you
little kid oh Jesus yeah that's about
right guys we go I don't know we can ask
Craig he's the movie dude he's got the
connections we could go on red carpet
access do a right by the Chinese know
the screeners Craig we'll probably the
screener by that no I don't get the
screener yeah I got the screeners for a
lot of other stuff though no see I still
got to see a bunch of movies I still
haven't watched a bunch to catch a plane
yeah yeah but I haven't watched all I
mean it's hard cuz you know you don't
wanna be depressed
amen surprise he's get you depressed
yeah all the Oscar screeners most of our
donors man they're like that movie yeah
this is just clash no no that's a
premises no no no no that supremacy [ __ ]
I can switch my weapons dude wait why
you've given Steve beef I thought I was
your favorite dude that's [ __ ] up I've
never ever said that quick dude you're
such a racist such a racist
for you guys that killing peeps we're
all in the center again heavy you look
pleased nice thank you crack oh god I
need help though I'm getting tagged
Center Center oh good job get that guy
Stevie there's another guy - you're
right Steve watch off pika pika that's
helpful
pika Pikachu beanie therapy my name's
Arthur damn it it's about to get the
heavy come on
okay both got it
TK thinks she can't got that smooth dick
for you Peaks that's what he said I know
hey good work good work good work
what do you mean we're doing good all
right come on how did this guy get away
oh that was beautiful dude
he's shield that I jumped over it and
he's cold fusion is ass break him up on
you thank you good to be shooting this
is the way we start sorry playing with
coal I know why don't we play this will
play trials dude really good they're way
down
dude they're really good boom back to
Center I'm excited to see here in the
episode Steve I think you're doing real
good
I think Steve's doing great with Phoebe
show I'm not even joking nothing I'm
trying I think it's pretty awesome when
you get a new guest like every week I'm
trying yeah they're good guys they're
super interesting yeah I mean you know I
try but it's like okay what species
homesick so a hip hop head I'd never
heard about and hearing the cool story
about their life or how they got yeah
that's so good la like legend dude you
know I mean like street cred like the
dudes he deserves it
mm-hmm are you talking about and he's
from the best talked about no can do I
can't look at that
no can't do come on beau you just asked
dumbfounded you should get at Rex TV on
he's an interesting cast seems cool very
interesting yeah
Rex TV screen yeah yeah his whole thing
is like stuff is like all frogs like his
stop along stuff it's all green it's
pretty dope it's all feed
yeah like healers like Green Timberland
not dead
how am I not there fully crap he's
actually on Netflix - I think it's that
um one that uh awkwafina and and
dumbfounded are on yeah back to Center
what about DJ DJ Kool Kris it's funny
you brought that up but I do want this
yeah I'm not joking yes yes there planet
or China whoa sure
and you know we're raising it all so I
mean it'd be gonna be cool I mean she's
a real EDC DJ can it's also DJ so you
know
also you should ask when dumped out is
for asking if you can get his DJ DJs
though he's pretty tough knows too bad
does uh this dude I know is plant
this dude i knows also got abandoned
he's in town from this week but he's
playing at MOCA god dammit god dammit
dead because he might be down for that
or it might be like on Conan or
something
dawn is coming Guardian finish this I'll
send you I'll send you a link to them if
you want me to ask him I know you're
probably busy and already that gets this
nice okay let me know cuz I know got
this boys I can I can ask them good job
boys - I wanna see christiev the pornhub
podcast episode what the food was
awesome it's so funny
alright you out alright alright let's
talk more and then we'll call them real
okay I'm gonna stop twitching no anyway
cuz alright guys good night ice cream
check us out on YouTube horse farts in
there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]